[Music]
it's seven o'clock i'm dermott manahan
you're watching sky news tonight and a
special question and answer program on
the war in ukraine the headlines the
prime minister science historic security
agreements with sweden and finland
pledging the support of the uk's
military if they come under attack
we face
a new reality
but one that we face together
throughout this conflict our nordic
partners have been leading international
support not just for ukraine but also
for european security
a strong message to russia from the
finnish president who says putin's war
has pushed them to consider full nato
membership
you caused this
look at the mirror
plus europe says gas supplies are stable
after ukraine blocked a pipeline from
russia
and belarus deploys troops to its border
with ukraine as they claim that western
allies are building their military
presence in the region
[Music]
a very good evening well tonight we hope
to answer as many of your questions as
possible after more than two months now
of the war in ukraine coming up in just
a moment i'll be joined by our security
and defense analyst michael clark but
first let's give you a summary of the
rest of the day's news
and the government has ruled out an
emergency budget to help with the rising
cost of living as a report today warned
that families will soon struggle to
survive the national institute of
economic and social research has
predicted around 1.5 million british
households will not be able to pay for
food and energy the prime minister is
under pressure to tackle the growing
crisis after the government's queen's
speech yesterday failed to set out any
short-term financial support
tributes have been paid to a journalist
who was shot dead while covering an
israeli raid in the occupied west bank a
palestinian reporter shirin abu aklay
who worked for al jazeera television was
killed in the town of janine al jazeera
has blamed israeli forces for her death
but israel has denied this and suggested
that reporters may have been shot at by
palestinian fighters
rebecca vardy has told the high court
that she was just joking in
conversations about leaking information
for money the mother of five is
currently suing colleen rooney after
being accused of giving false stories
about her private life to the press
a single uk ticket holder has claimed
the 184 million pound prize from last
night's euro millions draw it makes them
the uk's biggest ever national lottery
winner richer than the footballers harry
kane and paul pogba put together
well now the prime minister has signed
historic security agreements with both
sweden and finland pledging uk military
support if those countries were to come
under attack the two countries are
historically neutral but will now assess
whether or not to join nato with support
for the military alliance strengthened
by russia's invasion of ukraine well
boris johnson began the day in sweden
where he signed the first of the new
declarations alongside his counterpart
mark elena anderson mr johnson said the
deal would bring the countries closer
together with better intelligence
sharing as well as closer military and
technological ties
when europe celebrated ve day in 1945 a
victory that was of course
in no small part ensured
by the heroism of the russian people
we hoped that peace on our continent
would endure
well putin's bloodthirsty campaign
against a sovereign
nation
has put an end to that hope and we face
a new reality
but one that we face together
throughout this conflict our nordic
partners have been leading international
support not just for ukraine but also
for european security
and the swedish prime minister echoed mr
johnson's comments speaking of a
strengthened unity since russia's
invasion of ukraine
president putin thought he could cause
division
but he has achieved opposites
we stand here today
more united than ever
and with the ambition of strengthening
our bonds even more
and the russia russian aggression
against ukraine
has been met with incredible bravery
from the ukrainians and the ukrainian
leaders
but also by a unanimous condemnation and
firm response from the entire
transatlantic community and beyond
and a short time ago mr johnson signed a
similar deal with the finnish president
in helsinki who said russia only had
itself to blame for his country
considering joining the nato alliance
they are
ready
to attack
the neighboring country
so
when you ask whether
whether
what they
how they see
possible finnish joining
well
if that would be the case that we join
well my response would be that
you caused this
look at the mirror
analysis now with our security and
defense editor deborah haynes who joins
us from the ukrainian capital kiev and
deborah what then do these agreements
mean potentially in practice
well these these sort of security
assurances um they mean basically that
if for example
sweden or finland was attacked by russia
and no one is suggesting that that is
about to happen that both countries or
either country could call upon the uk
for assistance it's something that
ukraine you know all three countries are
not members of nato but ukraine didn't
have that kind of
a guarantee written in print that meant
that it could guarantee
assistance were it to be invaded which
of course it was and yes it has received
significant support from the uk from the
u.s and from other allies but the fact
that preemptively the uk is saying very
clearly that should uh sweden or finland
be attacked should they be invaded then
there would be british support and that
does act as a kind of deterrence and it
all also does draw those two countries
in closer because the uk is a member of
nato and so if you could take it that
extra step so say there's an attack on
finland say the uk responds say russia
is the attacker sees the uk response and
decides to attack the uk then that would
potentially then be an article 5 moment
with an attack on one being an attack on
all and again the thinking could be that
maybe an aggressor might think twice but
this all does come around at such an
important time for finland and sweden as
they consider whether to end their
long-held positions of military
neutrality for finland it's a position
they've had since the end of the second
world war for sweden it's been in place
for more than 200 years and we're
expecting to hear from the finnish
president tomorrow his decision on
whether or not his country should
request nato membership if as is
expected he signals yes they should then
that does begin a process that would
lead to them formally requesting
membership and that would be a huge
moment and the absolute opposite of what
president putin said he'd intended when
he invaded ukraine when he wanted less
nato at his borders instead he's going
to be faced with much more nato and a
nato that really has been galvanized
more than i've ever seen in my 20 years
or so of of covering defense issues
galvanized in the understanding of the
fundamental importance of security and
how without defending your security
pretty much everything else daily life
relies upon falls away as we're seeing
here in ukraine with families seeing
their houses devastated people killed
people uprooted and not knowing what the
security what the future holds
debra haynes in kiev thank you very much
indeed
well uh we're turning now to your
questions on the war in ukraine well
into its third month of course and our
security and defense analyst professor
michael clark is here to do his best to
answer them all and uh our first couple
of questions michael uh concerned that
issue we've just been discussing with
deborah let's start with a question from
anthony uh on that very issue how likely
is the threat of russia initiating an
attack on sweden if the uk provides aid
to sweden what is the possibility then
of russia retaliating against the uk so
so what does it all mean is it almost as
if sweden is in the anteroom of nato now
oh for sure i mean the swedish aircraft
are all flying nato missions alongside
nato aircraft around the edges of
ukraine to pick up intelligence the
swedes and the finns have been
effectively integrated into nato for the
last couple of years in all sorts of
politically acceptable ways so this is a
big big political moment but technically
sweden and finland just meld into the
alliance now there's nothing the
russians can do about that they'll go
berserk and we can predict predict that
all sorts of dark threats have been
issued but these threats are all very
vague say well there will be
consequences and this will upset the
european balance and we'll have to
redress the balance but you ask yourself
well what could they do the only thing
that the russians could do is start to
initiate in effect world war iii by
attacking sweden with you know i mean
air air delivered systems or threatening
nuclear war and so on um the fact is
most of the forces are now involved in
ukraine they they physically could not
attack either the baltic states or
sweden the baltic states say they've
never seen so few russians on the other
side of their borders they've never
because they've all gone
so there's almost nothing the russians
can do apart from complain which they
will and issue more veiled threats and
those threats might be quite blood
curdling but they're not regarded as
credible um
would britain you know would there be
retaliation against britain well
there could be
more cyber attacks on britain i mean
britain is in the is in russia sites
here they they think that we're
manipulating everything they think the
the americans listen to us and the
americans are doing what we advise them
they pay us this enormous respect of
thinking that somehow we are the we're
the machiavelli behind everything if
only that were a little bit true but it
isn't um but they might try and cyber
attack us and i suspect that there may
be some aspects of retaliation
particularly for boris johnson being so
um overt in saying you know the
americans won't give these guarantees to
sweden and finland in advance of their
membership and we're saying okay well we
will insofar as we can we will okay
michael well we've got a question now
from john continuing on this particular
theme and more or less asking if sweden
and finland have been offered these
guarantees why haven't they applied
to ukraine the uk has signed this
agreement with sweden and finland to
support the countries if they're
attacked if an aggressor were to attack
with uk military on the ground would
nato have to get involved no is the
answer
again it's extremely unlikely but the
nato treaty the article 5 guarantee that
an attack on one will be regarded as an
attack on all only applies to nato
territory and so in safari sweden
finland are not yet nato territory any
force is operating outside nato which in
sweden and finland they would be for the
next few months uh the article 5
guarantee wouldn't apply so you know
nato has no responsibility to come to
the aid of the allies if they're in the
middle east or in afghanistan or
whatever they often do because they're
nato and they think the same way about
something i mean in the gulf war in 1991
the whole of nato transferred itself in
effect to fight in the gulf because they
trained to do it for 50 odd years and
now they did it in the gulf
not because they were nato but because
they knew how to do these things and
they all wanted to be there because they
all agreed with each other
let's stay uh with the issue of nato our
next question is from emma who asks this
is nato essentially fighting a proxy war
against russia well that's the charge
that russia's been making for quite some
time yeah and the answer is yes
absolutely it is i mean this is what a
proxy war is where you provided the
means you give support you give money
you cheer from the sidelines and
somebody else does the fighting that's a
proxy war that's what nato is doing the
difference is the only difference is
that usually in proxy wars they say that
well the person doing the supporting
persuades the person doing the fighting
to do the fighting to put their necks on
the line for your sake it didn't happen
that way around the ukrainians were
fighting because they were trying to
defend their country against an invasion
nato wanted to help them so you know
nato doesn't want to be in this position
although it might come out ahead in the
in the event because of it but we're
going to go through some very dangerous
monsters well it's i mean it is the most
dangerous scenario that if russia
decides okay we are fighting this proxy
war against nato why do we just attack
nato forces in a nato country who are
supplying the ukrainians yeah which is
why nato doesn't want russia to see this
as a war
for its survival you know in ukraine
they're fighting for their survival and
nato is helping and because we don't
want the russians to feel that they are
fighting for their survival or the
gloves really will come off therefore
we're doing it in a rather nato who's
doing it in a rather restrained way but
is it a proxy war yeah you bet it's a
proxy war okay uh let's talk about the
balance of forces as we understand them
at the moment this question from leanne
uh asking us the ukrainian military
suffers loss and we don't really know
the scale of those injury and exhaustion
what happens when they no longer have
the numbers to maintain their defense
will the allies send in troops well what
do we know we hear a lot about russian
losses what do we know about on the
ukrainian side uh only estimates because
the ukrainians don't issue numbers and
nobody presses them to do it because uh
they want to help
but the view is it's probably between a
third and a half in terms of personnel
losses we know that their equipment
losses are only about a third the the
russians have lost about three and a
half thousand pieces of equipment sorry
two and a half thousand pieces of
equipment
and it looks as if ukraine has lost
about 800 significant pieces of
equipment so they are they are losing
forces but one thing that we we ought to
be aware of is that as this war goes on
ukrainian numbers in terms of troops on
the ground will favor ukraine more than
russia why so because ukraine is fully
mobilized they're fighting for the
survival so they've got their army of
only 125 000 but they've got reserve
force of 900 000 of whom at least 300
000 have been in the donbass over the
last eight years they've actually fought
on and off so the ukrainians have
effectively got an army of about four
hundred thousand battle hard battle
hardened because they're fighting for
their lives now the russians have got a
standing army of 280 000 only they've
got about a million people under arms
900 000 of whom about 400 000 are
interior troops basically troops against
their own population so their standing
army is only 280 000 and they committed
190 of that 280 000 to this operation so
as this war goes on unless the russians
are prepared to mobilize
they may they may unless they mobilize
then the troop numbers will start to
work against them as this thing goes on
because that's our very next question
this one from neil saying if russia
declared war on ukraine would this
remove barriers that prevent ukraine
from attacking strategic targets within
russia and so part of that point you've
already addressed in terms of yeah it
would turning it from a special military
opportunity
it would make it legally okay for the
ukrainians to attack strategic targets
however again you come back to this
point it's not in ukraine's interest to
make the russians feel that they're
fighting for their survival because then
the war would go towards the world war
three scenario which is what everybody
wants to obviously avoid
okay uh and in terms of the strategy
michael is from ross saying that
if there is a prolonged stalemate in the
east how valuable is this russian land
bridge through mariupol which of course
they still haven't fully taken and what
are ukraine's options to disrupt a key
region in the in the whole battleground
yes that's what we've been saying i mean
the russians can conquer this land
bridge between the donbass and crimea
they can even push as far as you know
michelle evan even if they got past
michelle towards odessa they can conquer
it but then they've got to hold it
because essentially there are several
million people who live there who don't
want them to be there and when you try
to hold a place again the numbers work
against you um in all in an ordered
society you need two people per thousand
members of the population to keep order
that is in in london two per thousand in
a disordered situation like say northern
ireland at the peak of the troubles you
need 20 per thousand
and the russians in chechnya had 130 per
thousand so you just work it out that's
if you're occupying forces conversing
the local population yeah if the people
don't want you there and are prepared to
be uh to to demonstrate and to be to to
to rebel in significant ways you need at
least 20 per thousand upwards of that
and while that is happening the russians
are probably still going to be fighting
the ukrainian army so what they face in
this land bridge even if they conquer it
is a constant rebellion plus fighting
the ukrainian army elsewhere in ukraine
unless the ukrainians are prepared to
say okay we'll stop and negotiate which
they absolutely won't at the moment and
that was repeated again by caleb
yesterday in an interview she said no no
we are not negotiating foreign
um unless they are prepared to say that
then the ukrainians will keep fighting
and the russians simply don't have the
numbers to do it let's look out to see
peter has this interesting question the
black sea has full freedom of movement
for all vessels enshrined in
international law of course if this is
the case why are the western powers
supporting ukraine unable to send
supplies through the port of odessa
which of course is still in ukrainian
hands and it's blockaded yeah um
in theory this
this could be a runner sometime later on
in the war if the russians start to lose
badly and are not involved in blockading
odessa
that so i wouldn't rule this out but you
have to rule it out at the moment
because if if um if supplies even i mean
the turk turkey who control the straits
the bosphorus under the 1936 montreal
convention could object to war supplies
going through there'll be an interesting
legal question there but if you if you
could send war supplies through the
russians would would stop them they'd
block they'd actually intercept those
supplies and so the west would then have
to somehow intercept the russians so
very quickly there would be a naval war
going on in the black sea so present it
would bring nato and
russia's black sea fleet into direct
conflict which is what everybody wants
to avoid but i wouldn't rule it out at
some time in the future if this war
changes its character you know maybe
into next year okay we're going to take
a brief pause now michael thank you very
much indeed for what you've told us so
far you are watching a special question
and answer program on the war in ukraine
next we're asking why is the united
states and europe giving military aid to
ukraine instead of negotiating a
possible end to the war stay with us
[Music]
yes so i found out about three weeks ago
i was nominated from um my colleague
jasmine haroon um i'm a football coach
in redbridge and she nominated me for
the work i'm doing um yeah so i'll be
doing carrying the button on the fifth
of june
very very excited and once in a lifetime
opportunity i'm just full of gratitude
that you know someone like me that's
getting to hold the um button and just
aesthetic and really grateful for it and
yeah looking forward to it i'm a
football coach
coach girls
especially within the south asian
community and i also go into schools and
help support teachers run football
sessions for the let's go play campaign
i work for an fa community champion and
i help and recruit coaches and support
them on their journeys into coaching and
i'm also a fa mentor i support young
leaders delivering
football projects in the community i
haven't had a chance yet to have a look
at it i'm not sure
where exactly i'm going and i know it's
going around really great landmarks and
great journeys so looking forward to it
but yeah and i'm waiting to know how
long i have to hold it for lots of
distance
yeah so i'm really looking forward to
knowing all that
[Music]
[Music]
the inspiration behind our product came
from
understanding how big of a problem
livestock meat and emissions were
welcome back i'm with professor michael
clark and your questions about the war
in ukraine let's uh crack on and we've
got
a question here about uh the us and
europe and its aid too ukraine asking
why is the us and europe more interested
in giving military aid to ukraine
instead of negotiating for peace and an
end to the war well michael is it and is
it the u.s and europe's place to
negotiate and enter the war
no not directly but i take exactly the
point of the question i think it's a
really important question because the
answer is that the western world has had
to decide
is this something where we want to end
the war at all costs or is it something
where we have to take sides in a
conflict that really matters to us you
know most most wars that occur even
these uh issues in the middle east and
around the fringes of europe we say it's
a crisis we've got to manage
the view that the western powers have
taken from the very beginning is this is
not a question of managing this crisis
we've got to prevail we've got the
ukrainians have got somehow to win and
we've got to win because what is what is
at stake here is not just a war that
we'd rather was not taking place it is a
threat to our security to our values to
the liberal democratic order to
civilized behavior and so the view the
west is taking rightly or wrongly and in
my view rightly is that this actually is
a choice of sides
and that this war has got to end with
the restoration of ukrainian full
ukrainian sovereignty whatever that's
going to be does this approach evolve
during the course of the conflict
because there was that flurry of peace
talks earlier on that's right in the
conflict and now have the objectives of
the us and europe change i think they
have they've hardened because the fear
is and you hear this in germany all the
time is that those who say look we want
an end to the war so we can get back to
trade means that we're going to reward
aggression again are we so the russians
invaded crimea twice in 2014 and we let
them and they've done it again in 2022
so we'll let them get away with that as
well shall we a little bit and then when
they do it again in 2026 we'll give them
another piece um the the sense is that
at the moment negotiation feels like
appeasement that's the way it is okay
well with that scenario here's a
question chris asks this one which is
very good it sets it up more or less
than asking if that's your objective why
not get properly involved chris asked
during the korean war china thought
nothing of the fact that the u.s was a
nuclear power
in going to the aid of north korea and
intervening against u.n forces why is
the u.s not taking the same stance with
ukraine i brush off the fact that russia
is a nuclear power and get involved well
it wasn't that safe even in 1950 because
if you remember um although china did uh
invade
invaded north uh korea just as the
americans were up to the yalu river at
christmas uh in 1950
and macarthur who was the commander the
american commander in the pacific
started saying that we should use our
nuclear weapons we've got these new
weapons why don't we use them on china
and he was sacked for it truman very
rightly said you can't go around saying
this sacked him so it wasn't that um
nuclear politics were completely absent
in the korean war but i take his point
very very clearly
the world is full of examples of power
of nuclear powers being attacked or
defied i mean the falklands the falcons
were attacked by argentina you know
argentina went to war with us even
though we've got nuclear weapons they
took no notice of them um the taliban uh
the the north vietnamese fought the
americans even though they were nuclear
the taliban fought the americans even
though they're nuclear the issue is that
unless you're talking about national
survival going back to russia's sense of
national survival unless you're talking
about national survival the general view
is nuclear politics don't come into it
and so a
a a country can attack a nuclear power
if the objectives are so limited that
the nuclear power doesn't think this is
be all an end-all for us so we don't
want nuclear powers attacking nuclear
powers presumably in
the korean war china wasn't a nuclear
power no no no china didn't explode
nuclear bomb until
1964. all right well uh continuing uh
with that theme about nuclear weapons
vanessa asks this in the event that
russia deploys a long-range nuclear
missile on any nato or non-nato country
could this missile be intercepted and
destroyed well we've uh asked about that
a few times on programs like this i mean
what is the the technological capability
of the united states in particular to
bring down these missiles basically i
mean cruise missiles travel at about the
speed of an aircraft 600 miles an hour
and they can be shot down that's
relatively slow and you can see them and
they travel relatively low
so any missile that's traveling you know
air breathing as they say which
traveling through the air is potentially
vulnerable to modern defensive systems
and the united states west the western
powers have got quite a lot of defenses
that could could do some against those
ballistic missiles are very hard to
defend against because a ballistic
missile you know is fired goes into the
lower low earth or atmosphere and then
comes down again i mean when it's fired
it only burns for about 120 seconds so
it burns for about two minutes so that's
when it's most vulnerable just after
it's been fired but from the defender's
point of view it's too far away and you
haven't got time to do much about it by
the time it's it's finished firing then
it's on pure ballistics it's just
dropping so it's going up into the
atmosphere then it's too high to do
anything about you can't get to it by
the time it's coming down it's too close
and going too fast
so at the time when you can get at it
it's too close too fast so ballistic
missiles are very hard to defend against
there are some defense against one or
two
but nobody can can tell you that the
systems which presently exist could
defend against 10 or 12. and certainly
not absolutely not against 50 or 60.
can't be done good demonstration by the
way there michael i don't think you've
ever found a biro so terrifying um we've
got this one from russell uh asking this
do you think russia will try to take the
whole of ukraine in the near or distant
future or will putin be satisfied taking
the donbass region well this is the at
the heart of the question now what are
the russian intentions what are putin's
intentions well they may be changing
because he must now know that he can't
have the whole of ukraine as long as the
ukrainians are prepared to keep fighting
we know that's what he wanted because
that's what he essentially said before
the invasion he said ukraine just has no
right to exist it's it's little russia
that's what they used to call it little
russia it's all part of russia and we
the the ukrainians themselves the uh
ukrainian intelligence services have
produced stole
reports that they say they've got hold
of not stolen reports but reports that
they've intercepted um which shows that
the russians intended in the first stage
of the attack to take the whole of
ukraine which actually confirms what
western intelligence said so there's no
question about it in my mind the
russians intended to take the whole of
ukraine
the objective may now be to grab as much
territory as possible try to wear down
the west europeans uh with their resolve
trying to wear down the ukrainians
negotiate and somehow pull back with a
land bridge to crimea uh uh land bridge
crimea maybe to odessa as gain i mean my
own view is that's for reasons i
mentioned earlier it's not realistic so
keep fighting for it but what happens in
that eventuality some kind of stalemate
and then presumably ukraine just becomes
an even more armed camp yeah if if the
fighting stops on the front lines for a
while everyone just re-arms exactly and
the ukrainians themselves they say this
all the time they say you know putin is
determined to elab to uh get rid of
ukraine altogether he said you know he
doesn't believe ukraine should exist so
as far as we're concerned we are under
constant threat and so even if we did do
a deal now it's only a pause before they
try it again and try it again and so we
have no alternative they say but to arm
ourselves and be prepared to fight in a
generational sense this for they you
know they say this will go on now for
the next one or two generations that's
the only way we can preserve our
statehood they're very clear and very
honest about that and their fights are
fight we have to support that's what we
say michael thank you very much indeed
for the time being uh we are more or
less at half time in this uh question
and answer session uh you're watching a
special session as i say special
programme about the war in ukraine next
we're going to be asking and examining
what is the state of the russian army
right now after as i say coming into the
third month of fighting
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
so
[Music]
you're very welcome back i'm with
professor michael clark and your
questions about the war in ukraine and
we've got a very simple straightforward
one but it's the question we all want to
know came in through twitter what is the
state michael of the russian army what
are we nearly 80 days into the conflict
yes and it's looking pretty poor
um it's worse than most of us thought it
would be i'm sure it's worse than the uh
russian generals thought it would be
garasimov who hasn't been seen
incidentally since he was apparently
wounded a week ago in israel he wasn't
he wasn't in red square he wasn't in red
square so either he's in disgrace or
he's in hospital he was supposed to have
had just a scratch in the thigh but well
we'll see
but it's been a shock to them for sure
so this i mean everything is wrong with
the russian army in a way i mean
structural issues one is that they
haven't conducted big operations since
uh manchuria since they invaded
manchuria in 1945 to take from japan and
the battle of berlin so this is the
biggest operation since 1945. all the
things they've done in the last 10 or 15
years have been by their elite forces
and their air force working with local
militias on the ground and with their
private security people like the wagner
group i see so when it comes to the air
force for instance the operations in
syria there was no
real air resistance there was no air
defenses there no exactly they didn't
need them that's the point and so they
uh they didn't need to deploy their army
in a war fighting capacity whereas
western armies have done lots of
operations since the end of the cold war
british the british army has been on 12
major significant operations you know
good bad indifferent but they've they've
learned by goodness they've learned so
that's one structural issue another one
is corruption
i don't think anybody understood quite
how deeply corruption had gone right
through the uh soviet forces russian
forces so that a lot of their equipment
which was supposed to be up to date
wasn't because a lot of it had been sold
or never procured in those numbers in
the first place like i mean down to
things like radios in tanks gps systems
in their armored vehicles not enough of
them because they
if they were supposed to have two you
know million and a half gps systems they
obviously didn't or somebody flogged
them off you know long before they were
needed so there's a lot of corruption
and then just bad leadership i mean from
the top down and the the thing that we
chatted about occasionally before is the
lack of ncos the lack of sergeants and
corporals these are the people who are
the backbone of an army because the
officers give their orders but it's the
sergeants and the corporals working with
20 men or in western western case men
and women very often to actually make
them into a cohesive unit make them help
help them to carry out the orders and
they've always had the old red army had
a very weak cardra of ncos
non-commissioned officers and that's
gone over into the russian army so top
to bottom um they have been
far more inefficient than we all thought
they would be fascinating let's uh find
out more then about the ukrainian side
carolina has tweeted to ask this what
are ukraine's main techniques in in
defense and attack and presumably
they've adapted over the last few months
in the battle yeah i mean there's two
layers here to defense and attack it's
it's known in the trade as a big hand on
a small map if i put my hand on a map
and i say yeah the russians are
advancing here and the ukrainians are
defending here that's true what goes on
but underneath my hand there are lots of
of withdrawals and attacks and
encirclements and maneuvers and all the
human characteristics come in the
heroism and the cowardice and accidents
and killing
underneath your hand there are many wars
going on even though these one hand is
advancing one hand is retreating and so
um it comes down it's a bit like sport
you know they say a batter in cricket
you've got to have a good defensive game
before you can make any runs before you
can go into the attack in soccer you've
you know you've got to be able to defend
the ball even as you're going up the
wing with it in attack so attack and
defense are not two different things
they're they're soldiering in this case
it's what the military do it so the
macro level it comes down to the
individual quality of the training the
motivation all the rest of it at the big
level the ukrainians are facing quite an
important point at the moment because
they're doing very well in these local
counter-attacks they're frustrating the
russian strategy at more or less every
turn
but they can't just drift from that into
a real offensive to throw the russians
out even though they're talking now in
those terms because to go on to the
offensive to go on to a strategic
offensive they've got to organize
themselves differently equip themselves
differently get ready for it you know if
you're if you're attacking for defensive
reasons
you can't just keep on doing that you've
then got to pull back you've got to work
yourselves in in a different sort of
order and then you've got to create an
offensive and then start it and roll it
forward and will those of us in this
business will be watching to see if the
ukrainians look as if they're going to
start to do that
so are we potentially approaching that
phase
not yet not yet but the ukrainians think
they might and if i mean pure guesswork
if they would continue to do as well as
they're doing and if the russians
continue to do as badly as they're doing
then you know let's say in the late
summer or autumn we might begin to see
the ukrainians put together some big
strategic offensive moves as opposed to
these local local offensive moves which
are part of their defense let's examine
the air campaign a bit more now we've
touched on it and of course a huge
factor in this conflict this from alex
saying are you surprised
how the air battle has unfolded and what
seems to be a lack of air-to-air combat
and can i add in of course uh the
inability of the russian air force to
get supremacy of the skies yeah he's
exactly right i think we're all
surprised i mean we were wrong about
this we all said those of us in this
business that the russian air power
because it this is what has been used
around the world before and has been
pretty efficient at what it needed to do
or said it wanted to do
and we thought that they would actually
sweep away ukrainian air power pretty
quickly within 48 hours 72 hours so the
ukrainians will be left with just bits
and pieces and they haven't done it
now again the the russian air force has
shown it is not good at running complex
operations so they they can fly in
drop their bombs set off their missiles
or engage with other aircraft then they
fly home again but they don't actually
engage in this air ground support in the
way that they need to the way nato air
forces do all the time complex air
operations and are there any of these
these dog fights taking place no because
the well not many because fundamentally
this isn't an air-to-air con contest
this is an air-to-ground contest it's
concert between aircraft and
anti-aircraft systems on the ground
which are very good and one of the
lessons we're all taking from this which
in the west is actually quite important
is the the efficiency of these
ground-based systems is more than we
thought it was and so the the the
russian air force is more frightened of
what's on the ground than ukrainian
aircraft 200 miles away but the
ukrainian air force is still flying it
is they owned well they started with
about 120 flying aircraft and quite a
few helicopters they look as if they may
have 50 or so left
and they may get some more um so they've
lost about half the the russians started
with about 320 in this system they've
got they've only got about 800. people
say they've got 4 000 they haven't on
paper they've got 4 000. they've got
about 800 serviceable combat aircraft um
and they committed 320 about to this
operation they probably have only lost
25 or 30 of them but although they
haven't lost that many aircraft they're
not performing very well they're not
having much effect because their pilots
are not well enough trained and they're
too
too frightened but they're nervous of
the ground-based anti-aircraft systems
which are proven to be extremely
effective okay well let's talk about
missiles now and this from lorraine
saying why don't ukrainian forces launch
missiles against the kremlin and force
russia onto defense rather than offense
now i mean if she's really asking about
the kremlin yeah that's that's moscow
well that's about 500 miles away from
you yeah i mean one is that the um and i
know what you mean that the um i mean
one is that the ukrainians don't have
those sort of missiles and two goes back
to what we said before
to to as it would bomb the kremlin would
be to make war strategic war on russia
as a threat to russia's existence or a
threat to the very government itself of
russia and again the ukrainians don't
want to do that they want to win this
war by throwing the russians out they
don't want to enter into a war for
survival
with a country that is ten times bigger
than they are with a population four
times bigger than they are i mean that's
not a sensible thing to do so the
ukrainians want to win what is what is
for them a war of survival what is for
the russians
an adventure it's a putin adventure war
a war for conquest but you know bombing
the kremlin even if they could would
turn it into a mutual war for survival
in which they would definitely so and it
reinforces that message doesn't it that
we are no threat to you if you leave us
alone exactly exactly stay off our
territory accept that we are a nation
say the ukrainians and we'll all live
peacefully what you know what why would
we ever want to attack russia you know
why would we want to attack a country
ten times bigger than us okay uh
question another one coming in by
twitter many many questions coming in
this way uh asking why did ukraine not
attack russian railways to stop the
movement of tanks from belarusian areas
and not just russian railways then in
belarus itself where of course many of
the russian forces masked before the
invasion but we have heard reports
haven't we
some very brave people in belarus
working on the railways um carrying out
acts of suffering yes i mean my answer
to the question is that how do you know
they didn't yeah um
it's been a lot of it's been a lot of
sabotage of the railways however i mean
ukraine again doesn't want to drag
belarus into this the belarusians are
keeping out of it interestingly at the
moment i mean they may or may not
eventually but they are staying out and
the ukrainians want to keep them out
because uh you know dealing even with
the belarusian army is just a problem
they don't want to have um but also
the best way to attack a railway is
through sabotage it's very hard to
attack railways efficiently from the air
it's very hard to hit railway lines from
the air and in ways that they can't be
repaired the best thing to hit a roadway
bridges they're harder to repair
but in general railways have a very good
track record as it were of getting up
and running again and from the second
world war onwards the allies found it
really hard to destroy german railways
you can bomb them
but you can't take them out of the out
of the equation so easily so yeah
bombing railways is a is a way of you
know you spend a lot of energy to for
relatively poor results usually sabotage
is always the best way okay another
question uh about casualties uh this one
from peter who asks assuming 15 000
russian soldiers have been killed in the
war to date that's uh one of the i
suppose one of the core estimates isn't
it who is responsible for the
repatriation of the bodies um
we hear that quite often they're not
being repatriated
yes um the stories are i mean who is
responsible is the russian military it's
the you know the state is responsible
for repatriation and remember
repatriating bodies is a very uh modern
phenomenon um a little bit of it
happened in the first world war families
who were rich enough to bring the bodies
of their loved ones back it didn't
happen very much in the second world war
in any war subsequently it was only
since the 1990s
um that people
assumed that bodies would be would be
brought home it's a fairly modern thing
um
the stories going around these are
unconfirmed but these reports there's
quite a lot of them
are that first of all there were mobile
crematoriums that the russians took with
them and so there's a lot of a lot of
bodies will have been committed to
crematoria
and um that a lot of bodies have been a
lot of russian bodies have been taken
back and buried in mass graves which are
secret military installations
and the parents are being told that
they're all missing in action
um we can't confirm these reports but
there's a lot of anecdotal evidence on
russian media insofar as there isn't an
unofficial media um that people are
beginning to notice that so many of them
can't have been missing in action
um because these bodies have just been
spirited away oh my goodness me okay
michael we're taking another break now
and uh you're watching a special
question and answer program on the war
in ukraine next we're asking should
russia under this current regime ever be
allowed back into the western
international community stay with us
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
i'm lisa dowd and i'm sky's midlands
correspondent we can reveal that the
driver who hit harry dunn is 42 year old
and so cool ass just met the president
and we never thought we'd get this far
this is what they're up against is back
breaking
work water levels are dropping but no
one knows what impact further rain will
have
what would you do if this place wasn't
open
we take you to the heart of the stories
that shape our world
it's really scary in this community i'm
told that everybody knows someone
affected by covid
change seems tantalizingly close in this
corner of the uk
this is my patch my specialism it's also
my home
welcome back as you know i'm with
professor michael clark and your
questions about the war in ukraine uh
let's get some more in this from john uh
asking about the gas is russia still
paying ukraine transit fees for the
russian gas that flows through pipelines
on ukrainian land into europe i mean
quite extraordinary if that is the case
but the gas is still getting there and
it's not going through the new pipeline
so presumably there yeah yeah they don't
know they're paying transit fees it's
worth about uh 2 billion dollars a year
to ukraine
which you know in normal times would be
worth money worth having but given that
the ukrainians are just about to get a a
package from the americans worth 40
billion dollars it puts it into
perspective because they're they're
burning through money like there's no
tomorrow because they're fighting
a war so yes the transit fees still
exist the ukrainians played games a bit
with the pipelines this this week
because they said look the pipeline that
comes through eastern luhansk which is
in russian hands
is not secure and we're not going to
supply
europe through that pipeline because
they said look the separates have been
stealing gas from us for years they've
been sabotaging that pipeline and
leaking off gas and so on we can't put
up with it any longer
the thing is that most ukrainian gas i
mean ukraine provides about a pipeline
pipelines the pipelines through ukraine
provide about a third of europe's gas
and most of what comes from ukraine goes
to germany italy austria so those
countries are really severely affected
and what the ukrainian said is we're
stopping this pipeline because the the
russians are playing games with it but
we want to transfer it to the sutter
pipeline this sort of pipeline is
further west and runs through areas that
ukraine still controls and interestingly
gazprom the russian gas company they
went along with it they went along with
it and they did transfer quite a lot of
gas to the soda pipeline not completely
but quite a lot because gasprom want to
keep the pipelines flowing and everybody
wants it so what the ukrainians were
doing they were they were flexing their
muscles a bit it was probably a foolish
thing to do because it upset germany and
italy
don't do it you know you need their
support so keep the pipelines flowing
and you know
while this war is going on there is
still a commercial trade in gas
extraordinary but it will run down
after the end of this year well you
mentioned germany and gas of course
right at the heart of it that's our next
question about that can germany refuse
to purchase through north stream one
that's the existing pipeline and insist
on supply through ukraine the survival
of ukraine then becomes a necessity for
both europe and crucially russia you
better talk to us more about pipelines
yeah well um the point is it's a matter
of capacity nordstrom one is full now
which is why i mean it's full capacity
um it's operating at full capacity more
or less nordstrom 2 which is now
canceled more or less forever was going
to create new capacity supplying gas
directly from russia straight into
germany and thence to the european
networks which would have cut ukraine
out of it nordstrom 2 is now dead as far
as we know indefinitely um and so the
ukrainians as it were can uh still uh be
intrinsic to this system but if the
germany if german said we want to take
everything through nordstrom one they
simply couldn't get enough gas through
those pipelines at the moment just just
to continue with that question uh also
asks uh how long can russia survive
without this money and uh of course vice
versa how long can europe survive
without the gas yeah well um
russia is getting about um five billion
dollars a week
uh from europe in energy it's about
seven hundred million sorry dollar euros
700 million euros a day so that's about
5 billion euros a week so 250
billion euros a year
in
energy money
it's not the money that's the problem
for europe it's the availability for
germany italy and austria and hungary
and slovakia those the countries that
are really stuck
but if they if we reduce our european
gas requirements by the end of the year
then the sufferer then is russia because
they a they lose the money they'll lose
about that 250 billion a year which
they're getting and b they can't sell
the gas easily to anyone else because
you can only sell it to whoever's on the
other end of the pipeline it will take
them several years to build more
pipelines to asia and china which is
what they intend to do and so also when
you have to close down a pipeline
because nobody at the other end is
buying it it damages the whole system
and it takes months to get it back up
and running again i mean pipelines have
to flow and be full to be healthy they
can't just stop and so the russians are
the ultimate losers for this year the
situation is very uncomfortable for
europe on gas but by the end of the year
or into next year it will start to ease
on the present plans and then the loser
becomes the russian economy let's turn
to war crimes and some of the atrocities
being perpetrated by the russian forces
this question why can't the
international community begin
proceedings with a war crime trial now
as we have enough evidence are we afraid
of putin well it's happened before you
can try them in absentee you can start
the proceedings now the evidence is and
has been gathered yeah well um yes only
in a manner of speaking lord copper
because you know the evidence is very
hard to to to bring to a level that the
court can accept it i mean we've got
lots of video of of what looks like a
clear case of soldiers shooting
civilians but that alone would probably
wouldn't get a conviction because you
have to have supporting evidence you
have to be able to prove that you know
the
civilian didn't get in the way
accidentally that the soldier intended
to suit the civilian the soldier knew
this person was a civilian the soldier
didn't let the gun go off accidentally
usually you need
witness statements you need documentary
evidence some other
some form of intelligence so having
these these video clips is fundamentally
important but of themselves they won't
get you a conviction so what i'm saying
is that war crimes evidence takes a long
time to gather so there's no reason that
it is starting now believe me but it
will be some years before this evidence
is in this state to get to a court yes
time for a last quick question michael
the big one should russia under this
current regime ever be allowed back into
the western international community and
should all sanctions continue to remain
in place whilst they remain in power
this is about putin
ultimately hasn't he second point first
yes i mean for as long as putin remains
in power i'm sure the sanctions will
stay in place because as we said over
the gas once europe is not so dependent
on russian gas there are no the
sanctions don't hurt us very much they
hurt the russians but they don't really
hurt us because there's nothing that the
russians have got in their economy that
we really want a few things but they can
only inconvenience us so the sanctions
will probably stay on for quite a long
time until putin goes
and going back to you know should russia
be allowed back into the community
nation yes of course but not putin's
russia because this is in the view of
most people in the west and certainly my
view this is a struggle between
aggression and law breaking for the soul
of the international system that we have
taken for granted an existential
struggle michael thank you so much we're
out of time where does it go thank you
very much indeed for more illuminating
answers to the questions sent in by sky
news viewers michael clark there and
you're watching sky news coming up in
the next hour boris johnson the prime
minister has signed security agreements
with sweden and finland as those nordic
countries consider joining nato stay
with us
[Music]
[Music]
you